there it is again
oh boy
sorry christopher let's get to it best
moves other than shireen dunking on you
on pftpm which technically would qualify
since it did happen yesterday other than
that there is a trivia question they're
telling me there isn't now there is
there is there isn't no there is there's
there's a trivia question okay so
all right so um
danielle hunter you know your vikings
player who's a little bit disappointed
with his contract right now
what country is he from do you know your
team let's go
i i i know that it's it's some country
other than the united states does that
count as a right answer uh yeah no it
doesn't jamaica get to know your team
better he's from jamaica man come on man
let me mention something real quick
there this is not the year to be making
the power play
to try to get more money not this year
not coming off of a season-ending neck
injury with the market softening and
you're making 14-4 on average next year
come back and play this year next year
make your power play there was an
article in the athletic yesterday that
said he's you know he's kind of venting
to friends and he doesn't know what he's
going to do we'll see what he does but
he's under contract for three more years
all right you get the first pick
favorite moves best moves whatever we
want to call okay things you liked about
day one in free agency go all right well
i think that i mean new england won the
first day of free agency they were the
splashes i'll be specific i'm gonna go
with take seven moves in one hey all the
moves by the i'm gonna go with i'm gonna
the whole thing they got the opt-ins all
of them they're all back no i'm gonna go
with the jays all right judon and jonu
just those two specifically about what
the patriots did you know we've talked a
lot yes they're front seven there's no
pass rusher there
judon is great against the run he's got
a great physical presence of course he
can get after the quarterback so that
fits perfectly with bill belichick we
know that he's the master of linebackers
the secondary's already in place they
need that and then jonu smith well bill
belichick's also kind of the master of
tight ends too we know that and that was
a missing part of their offense last
year so they get that back and a guy
that has got a special tap i mean
special talents he can run like a
receiver yet he's gonna be able to block
and be the second tight end and the
h-back and the full back and do all
those type of things so you know jonu
and judon big time moves for the
patriots that's specific enough for you
no it's not because it was supposed to
be one and i would have just gone with
johnny smith because that was the bolt
from the blue that was the lightning
from the clear air out of nowhere holy
crap the patriots are on to something
then the question was was it a fluke or
was a storm brewing and obviously a
storm was brewing beyond johnny smith
and when they got matthew judo and then
it was a full-blown hurricane for the
patriots for me it's got to be shaq
barrett it's got to be yeah to keep him
with a 17 million base average 36
million paid out over the first two
years the franchise tag would have been
19 million
uh it worked out well they gambled it
was a calculated gamble and the way the
timeline went i firmly believe the
buccaneers
made it clear to shaq barrett and his
agent drew rosenhaus here's the offer
it's on the table as of noon eastern we
start calling other pass rushers so if
you want it
you got it there it is just let us know
by noon what you're going to do and it
worked because by noon right at noon we
find out he's staying put he's taking
that money so when you consider joey
boses at 27 million a year and they got
shaq barrett to stick around for what
they're going to pay him
yes it's a sign of the times but also it
showed that they were able to squeeze
just the right way to get that deal done
yeah definitely i mean they they played
their cars right they knew you know the
market everything they've done
everything right
ever since the playoffs started
basically playoffs were great super bowl
free agencies been great restructuring
at contracts franchise tagging the right
people i mean yes
i'm shocked they kept all these guys uh
and you're right got jack barrett at a
pretty good damn price well i'm gonna go
to another one of the you know top top
contracts we saw yesterday
but get into the big uglies a little bit
go with joe tooney yeah i mean we don't
talk about interior offensive line but
man one thing we know from last year
and we we it all came to fruition in the
super bowl i mean we were saying a lot
through the second half of the year man
mahomes has been under a lot of pressure
man he escapes a lot and he makes it
look cool and makes 20 yard completions
but man is he under a lot of pressure
you know when we go back and watch
replays of a game you wouldn't realize
it and you go wow i can't believe how
many sacks he actually avoided well you
got one of the best guards at football
in toonie they needed that they you know
again you know i don't know whether
they're going to get into more of a
balanced offense or they just want to be
able to be better protecting and
versatile as far as screen game things
like that all of that but they got the
weapons in place in the past game now
it's about people protecting your star
quarterback and i thought that was a
great move by them
question with mahomes is it more
important to have the protection on the
outside or the inside you know i i it's
it's i thought about this a lot
i i
he could have you know i guess i would
say really i'd rather have the inside
within my homes if you're gonna make me
pick either one i feel like he can see
the outside guys he can make them miss
and he has that ability to now step up
or get out step up and get out to the
edge you know it's hard and even in that
game
last in the super bowl so many of the
plays were shaq barrett looping inside
and coming in you know through the guard
gap and those type of things to where
now he's got no choice but able to run
back and we saw what that did so i guess
what i'm saying is yeah i think you'd
rather have them more protection in the
middle
and we've heard the the explanations
from the edge rushers as they try to
track him down whether it's lateral or
whether it's just he keeps dropping back
and back and back what von miller told
us at the super bowl last year he just
keeps going back and back and you can't
get to him and yeah he's got that rocket
arm he can release it while he's back
peddling all right next one for me i'll
go corey linsley if we're gonna go
lineman because
uh and you think about the net
difference you take
the best center in football away from
aaron rodgers and you drop him with
justin herbert a guy who
has the potential to be one of the great
young quarterbacks already one of the
great young quarterbacks in the nfl has
the potential to be one of the best
quarterbacks in the nfl brandon staley
and what they're doing out there to just
try to kind of quietly
build a team
that's going to be as good as the rams
if it isn't all ready it's working in
that direction and yes they have the
chiefs to deal with but they're serious
about doing for their quarterback what
the chiefs are doing for theirs and that
that interior protection's so important
because if you've got if you've got guys
at guard and center that just are very
good and they start getting thrown into
the legs of the quarterback you can't
get anything going
offensively right so uh the money's well
spent it's a guy who's going to be in
charge of all the protections helping
justin herbert better understand the
game i was excited by that move for
justin herbert and the charters that's
the kind of thing they have to do if
they really want to become the team they
can be yeah especially with herbert
under center no definitely you know and
and you know again i don't know what
they'll they'll do a tackle going
forward and all that because russell
o'coon's still a free agent right
um
uh but but i think the the thing or no
no they have trey turner i got them
confused they got trey turner at guard
cut him but they cut him and then they
resigned filer and linsley i mean you
got joe lombardi as the offensive
coordinator he came from the saints it's
yeah we know about the passing game but
he's the saints have always been into
protecting the quarterback and being
able to be balanced and run the football
too and i think you see you know a
little bit of that there so that that's
a great job by the chargers
um i think
i'm going to go to the jets
i'm only going to say one last name
davis okay
but aha that's two players there's corey
davis and jared davis
two players
bam got it yes uh because first off i
think corey davis really fits what mike
or
mike lafleur will want to do i still
getting mike and matt mixed up mike i
mean he's going to be the guy the route
runner that they feed the ball over the
middle off the play action he's going to
do all that type of stuff and i think
it's a really safe bet and fits within
how you want to play on the offensive
side of the ball grout runner who's got
enough speed and things to beat you deep
and scare you that way and then jared
davis as you mentioned to start the show
i mean he's he's one of those guys or i
mean you just he's he pops on film you
watch the lions the last year he's going
who is this big sucker number 40 running
around you know taking on guards
knocking people's heads off and doing
all that he is going to be perfect for
robert sala i mean they both got bulging
veins in their neck they'll fit together
perfectly so i think that's a great
signing by that group and joe douglas
it's just funny yesterday morning after
the show i was talking to some people
about some free agents out there that
maybe we're not thinking about and
someone said hey there's a lot of teams
that are interested in jarrod davis and
it's probably not going to be a
long-term deal because he wants to
establish himself because he wasn't used
right in detroit it's probably going to
be one year seven million it was one
year seven million for carl uh for for
jared davis yes i i know and i looked to
see if there was a chance carl lawson's
middle name was davis so you could have
used all three but i can't find his
middle name uh last one for me and i'm
gonna go ahead and use two names as well
okay fine but it's the move that wasn't
made it's that no team
paid huge money to juju smith schuster
or kenny gallaudet i'll throw them both
in there no one took the bait with
gallaudet
the injuries last year
where's the value there watch will
probably get 23 million a year by the
time we're done in about seven minutes
but the real one that stood out to me
there was so much buzz and hype about
juju's miss schuster i know he brings so
much more to the table than just what he
does on the football field with the
dancing on the logo and the social media
presence and all that other stuff
but he's a number two receiver
what are you going to pay a number two
receiver first day of free agency and
how do you justify that if you have
anything other than a number one
receiver who's stuck under a slotted
rookie deal that you can't tear up right
you throw your entire
pass receiver depth chart out of whack
from a payroll perspective if you give
juju 15 million a year
because then you instantly have to give
your number one guy 20. so i just i i i
was happy to see the restraint exercised
that no one felt compelled to go make
that big splash and say we spent a bunch
of money
on a player who while very good i don't
want to this doesn't take anything away
from juju schuster as a player i was
just concerned that the other narratives
around him were going to cause someone
to get caught up in the moment
and and screw up
their their overall salary structure
offensively by paying him more than they
should i hear you mike i mean he's he's
an interesting one you're right because
we talk about him you know like he's a
number one in a superstar but he's not
what he really is is a really good
number two and you look at a guy like
corey davis who i think you know that's
what that is right a really good number
two we got a three-year 37 million
dollar deal i would i would bet you juju
is asking for more now gallaudet that's
a different conversation he might be in
the i'm asking for the 17 18 million
dollar a year type of thing and i get
that because i think gallaudet is a
legit number one but we got to go to
commercial that's a good conversation
nonetheless
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports